this is tacky
[Applause]
Honda for the longest time at Tekken was
fighting games of best kept secrets
second was never really the popular game
like that for years it lived in the
shadows of more popular fighting games
more known fighting games more
competitive fighting games but when the
other games fell flat Tekken finally got
its shot its chance to prove that none
of that was true that Tekken could be
the biggest best and most exciting
fighting game on the planet and this is
its story display consistent commercial
and critical success Tekken was really
the biggest competitive game in the
scene these days though you'd be
hard-pressed to call it anything other
than the most exciting fighting game in
the world
[Music]
who died is crazy my god
like most of the genres foundational
works Tekken wasn't always the game we
know today Tekken began its life as a
tech demo a chance for its developer
Namco to prove their designers could
make 3d characters that looked as good
as the competition but as the weeks and
months went on the experiment became a
fighting game first called rave war and
later Tekken Tekken meaning iron fist in
Japanese was built as a cheaper
alternative for arcades looking for a
game like Sega's innovative 3d hit
Virtua Fighter 2 it had a similar
aesthetic similar gameplay even similar
characters and that all makes sense
since the game shared a director but
Tekken had something that its biggest
competitor didn't a ps1 port it was like
a Christmas gift a bit I solved my bad
you know hidden it in like a shelf with
other PlayStation games don't like
taking was this you know being on the
best-selling console of the era helped
Tekken overtake Virtua Fighter in the 3d
space and it put it neck and neck with
its other major competitor Street
Fighter but there were other things that
helped I can stand out it might not have
been first to the punch but it was one
of the most finely tuned 3d fighters it
also had a more involved story than its
competitors which came alongside some
extremely memorable characters and
perhaps more importantly its combat was
a little more rooted in reality than the
plasma chucking anime s competition as
the years went on and Tekken evolved
that focused on hard-hitting action
right out of a kung-fu movie made it
stand out even more sure of their
fighting a guy in a leopard mask wasn't
exactly realistic but it was definitely
cool between the gameplay and the
aesthetics Tekken drew in a lot of
people it's like a mixture of
over-the-top and
it's just perfectly combined and it was
just different it was different but it
was interesting you know I like the
weight of the moves look when they hit
like it was dynamic it was very flashy
though it took a few games to sand off
the rougher edges Tekken turned many
players into fans for life and no one
exemplifies that more than me
the man widely considered the greatest
Tekken player of all time Oh 2000
Stilton and a chopper one puto echoes
nokogiri Tannen donde check out GTA
games I'm gonna eat on hang on choco by
the table
Maharani round
we're on the market always on the day
who boring increments in control here
Domo comes in gets a knee is the model
second player skilled dedicated and in
love with the game so much so that he
paid out of pocket to run tournaments
and get people playing the game but
these efforts didn't begin until much
later after Tekken really took off
[Music]
so tekken threes launch was a really
really big deal not just for Tekken but
I feel like for games in general right
Tekken 3 is where it went from like oh
just another fighting game to the game
everyone had to own right it was like a
reason to have a ps1 at that point
Tekken threes elaborate mocap graphics
and stronger more competitive design
blitz near universal acclaim
it sold millions of units and broke
Tekken into the mainstream
all of a sudden Tekken was the biggest
fighting game in the world but fighting
games as a whole we're about to face
their greatest obstacle western arcades
died in the late 90s and they took a lot
of genres with them shmoop beat-em-ups
light gun games all gone in a flash and
plenty of developers were caught
flat-footed when their cash cows no
longer had an audience which meant that
as the ps2 came out and marked the
beginning of a new generation for gaming
fighting game developers were forced to
rethink their games a street fighter all
but went away and with Sega's departure
from the console space Virtua Fighter
games went from yearly to once per
console generation but Tekken survived
these lean times and even thrived so
from the get go check it was never
really the popular game like that and
you know we just have to play for the
love of the game and that's that was
kind of how it was for Chucky and for
Tekken 5 while Tekken 4 5 6 and tag 2
didn't quite hit the critical and
commercial highs of Tekken 3 the games
performed well and kept Tekken chugging
along while much of its competition all
but vanished and it allowed Tekken's
competitive community to thrive too
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Tekken's competitive scenes started like
pretty much any other fighting games
arcade showdowns evolved into local
tournaments that slowly grew larger and
larger it had a place at Evo the biggest
fighting game tournament in the world
which is where some people began to
learn about how international the game
really was by then many in the West
realized the Tekken's best players
didn't just come from North America
Japan and Europe there were strong
competitors from all over the world
particularly Korea or Tekken's very best
still trained to impact arcades but if
you find old videos of arcades in Korea
not not every arcade not all the time
but if it was an event or you know that
all just before the event the arcades
were packed you couldn't even see any
screens cuz it was just bodies hundreds
of buggies in the way at Evo 2003
Tekken's first showing at the tournament
KVM shocked the American competition and
beat Ryan Hart to take first place in
Tekken Tag Tournament the Korean
overlords had arrived the mid-90s saw an
economic crisis across much of East Asia
and a lot of companies went out of
business including the one that shipped
Capcom's arcade games from Japan to
Korea but Namco's games still made it
out making Tekken into Korea's national
fighting game so Koreans have always
been the gold standard in Tekken that's
because all of their top players live
close together where they can kind of
travel and play on a regular basis this
was especially the case back when
arcades were still really popular and
the best players in the world would meet
up every day that's old and green arcade
to play slowly word of the Korean
players started to spread throughout the
rest of the world but their dominance
wasn't stopped by other player skills
Tech in itself was slowing too
in 2009 it missed out on evo and the fgc
pendulum swung away from tekken and it
was still you know relatively popular a
competitive space but the games weren't
necessarily pleasing that fanbase as
much there were a couple issues I think
people had with some of the newer
releases as time went on and it kind of
start to wane a little bit 2008 was a
huge year for the fgc Street Fighter 4
revived competitive fighting games
basically single-handedly it brought
back lapsed players and introduced a ton
of fresh blood to the scene Tekken
didn't go away but it certainly wasn't
in the spotlight and a street fighter
exploded Tekken began to fade so much so
that an entire generation of players
could retire and all the fade from
memory Tekken 6 and tag 2 were solid
games but they just weren't as big as
Street Fighter 4 and Marvel vs. Capcom 3
Tekken was in the right place at the
wrong time tuck in that the time was in
no way what it was what it is today
right the local tournament might have
had like 16 players at the most the
future of Tekken was in limbo
development on Tekken 7 was pushed back
and while the game eventually made it to
arcades in 2015 it was basically
unplayable for anyone in the West until
June of 2017 when he came out on
consoles worldwide but amidst the
missteps of Street Fighter 5 s release
Tekken 7 found new life
[Music]
Tekken 7 did everything right from slow
motion and high tension moments to
incredible hit sparks the gorgeous
graphics and the wild guest characters
it was designed to bring the hype and
that's exactly what it did
Tekken had always felt slightly out of
place slightly ahead or behind its
competitors but with Tekken 7 it was
finally in the right place at the right
time Tekken 7 doesn't change the formula
much in fact most of what made it stand
out from the other fighting games in the
90s is also what makes it stand out
today it's more complicated than just
about any other major competitor which
is a pretty stark departure from
industry trends there's room for
flexibility for you to be your own self
and express your personality you can
have ten people that use the same
character but they will all look
completely different
it has crazy bomb crunching heads
[Applause]
I can feel it in my loins and now the
industry-standard array of crazy guest
characters
[Applause]
but with its competitors lagging behind
taking out the chance to display some
incredible stories stories that were
always there just never in the limelight
knees years long dominance continued
into yet another Tekken game forcing an
entire new generation of players to
respect his name very very close second
is me is your champion for Evo Japan
2018 the legend is back knees legacy is
one of working his hardest to make
Tekken huge a legacy of playing as much
Tekken as possible and encouraging
others to play the game alongside him
and his performance in Tekken 7 only
served to remind people why he's called
the king of Tekken
[Applause]
no guys yo guys Diamond tell me that one
good though that will tell me that one
good girl of course guys please make
some noise for rocks dragons actually a
little then there was kou Don's who
shocked the world with his return to
competition my name is Ian twang boom
would have became a super cool
each other for young two ages on the
other hand and a turn your corner
Thunder she took on iron I love it Aztec
invaded in the mid-2000s coup Don's went
with it
choosing to get a job after finishing
his mandatory military service but after
his father passed away his search for
meaning and comfort brought him back to
the Negev and Omaha tomorrow them to the
chassis Nechayev on the popular oxide
you think about hasn't watching in the
choco need stop before she better
hundred thousand audience in digging one
on the border somewhat I know answer but
I will say rock okay and once he came
back he showed the world why he was
feared in his prime and the legend the
ghosts of Tekken past he's been doing
this since the beginning
have many opportunities here but again
what an impressive game there's no time
left and that is gonna do it and we are
a force in our grand finals it's going
to be a three out of five if Coonans
wants to be the global champion he has
to win two
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
second seven world champion but Tekken's
Renaissance didn't just spotlight
legendary Korean players in America
where most players didn't get access to
Tekken 7 until it was released on
consoles a group of dedicated players
was ready to overthrow the Korean
overlords Annakin a perennial American
favorite one combo breaker 2016 earning
a direct spot in the king of the Iron
Fist World Championship but instead of
taking the spot and sitting out the rest
of the year Anna Kim decided to decline
and earn his way back into the
tournament yeah I remember in 2016 for
the very first second tour in the North
American region they had a very funny
rule where each tournament winner would
qualify into the national finals but if
you qualify you couldn't enter and in
order to you know re-enter in these
tournaments you would have to relinquish
your spot in order to even compete I had
a you know I was in a position where I
was able to go to a lot of tournaments
and travel and compete so I wanted to
take make the most out of that
opportunity and I didn't want to let
that rule kind of stop me his story of
perseverance and dedication to the game
was out done though by a player from the
middle of nowhere who was ready to take
the world by storm Arslan Ashe a
Pakistani player with next to no
experience on the world stage came out
of nowhere to win evo Japan
my god the tension here at football such
a hard getting care you gotta be Great
Britain's arms and try to close out the
tourney but he's pushing him towards the
dangers of swing he's in Britain legs
again in the head in the feeling
champion Pakistan taking the tournament
over the Philippine despite a terrible
travel schedule visa issues and the fact
that he came from a scene almost no one
knew existed Arslan prevailed and then
she did it again
we probably all been waiting for
we have the shining star of Pakistan mr.
arson ash
at the wall rain
it's gonna hurt
Wow
what
but we can just as easily tighten it up
and make it so hard money
Wow Wow and just like that our slant ash
I mean so dominant this is crazy
it's gonna happen right now this
opportunity Oh Oh these rain clothes
that was a great
our plan
the best player on the planet
untouchable Arslan became the first
player to win both Evo's and the
unquestionable best Tekken player in the
world in under a year
he put Pakistani Tekken on the map and
showed the world the Tekken was about
more than just Korea bro he's still
undefeated against not just that he is
Tekken sevens meteoric rise finally put
it back on the same level as its
competitors and that recognition finally
let these stories years in the making
reach the masses Tekken as the best
gameplay the best moments and the best
storylines it has to be taken seriously
as a competitive fighting it's unknown
earth you can ignore Tekken 7 right now
right it's got the best looking game
it's got some of the best gameplay
I think it's cost some of the best
storylines a couple other fighting games
dis generation kind of faltered out of
the gate and they're great now but they
took time to get there Tekken 7 came out
great and has only gotten better and
it's only gonna keep getting better what
many call Tekken's Renaissance was
earned the game survived years of lean
times years of TP a game alive when
fewer and fewer people cared years of
championing the most difficult game the
most complicated game while the industry
moved away from that right now at this
moment Tekken has won almost no other
fighting game in the world does a fully
united community in love with the game
continuously pushing it forward a
community grinding it out celebrating
champions from all over the world and a
community that is always
ready for the next battle
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
bring that notification fell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]
you